Hello everyone, welcome back to the
show. It's your host Danny Hiong. As you
can see, I am joined by Professor Jang
Suin of Predictive History. Professor
Jang, thanks so much for joining me
today.
>> Thanks for having me, John, Danny.
>> Yeah. Well, let's get right to it then,
Professor Jang. So, I wanted to ask you
just right out the gate. Uh, in prior
shows and in prior programs, you have
said that the US Empire will lose the
war with Iran even before the war began.
Well, now we are over 13 days in this
and I want to ask you if you believe we
are witnessing your predictions in real
time and what have you made of Trump's
words today that Iran is actually on the
verge of surrender despite the fact that
you see and I can pull up some of those
images. We see Iranian officials or the
Iranian president, the Iranian foreign
minister, they're all out in the streets
on on coups day uh without a security
detail. what what talk about your
predictions of how this war will go and
whether we are seeing them bear fruit
now.
>> Right. So what's interesting about this
war is that the Americans and Iranians
have different strategies and therefore
they live in different um political
realities. So for the Americans and the
Israelis, they believe that what they
can do is decapitate the regime uh the
government and they've done that by
killing the Alata K&A and then put this
pressure on uh the military by
bombarding uh air defenses and military
infrastructure and then exert tremendous
pressure on the civil population by
embargoing the economy and then by um
embedding themselves and promoting put
in certain dissident groups uh whether
they be religious, political, or ethnic
groups in um Iran. They hope to create a
color revolution to eventually overthrow
uh the government. Okay. Basically, what
they're trying to do is provoke a civil
war in Iran. And so that's the American
strategy. And from their perspective, it
does seem as though things are going to
plan because again they have um
decapitate um the the ali the supreme
leader in the first day and um they've
hit civil infrastructure. So they
destroy these oil departs in Tran. So
you might have seen this video footage
of black um uh clouds and black air in
in Tran these past few days. um and they
are embargoing the um Iranian economy.
So they do believe it's going to plan.
There's talk of them arming insurgents.
Um from the Iranian perspective, their
strategy is very different. They
understand that the very basis of the
American American empire is actually the
global economy. So if you put enough
pressure on the global economy um you
would eventually force America to call
uncle. So, so what we so we're seeing uh
the first few uh days are sustained
attacks on American military in
installations throughout uh the GCC. Uh
the the American fifth fleet is based in
Ban. Um you are seeing sustained attacks
on Israel and in the first few days
actually um the main purpose of Iran was
to degrade the air defense of both the
Israelis and Americans basically to
blind them. And from reporting, it seems
as though uh the Iranians have achieved
this objective, meaning that uh most of
the interceptor inventory is gone,
meaning these Patriot missile defenses
are no longer relevant in this fight.
Also, what's much more relevant is that
it seems that much of the radar system
um is now depleted. meaning that
basically with $10,000 shiad drones
um Iran can cause tremendous damage to
the GCC and Israel. We we're already
seeing that in Dubai where um airports
where banks where data centers um are
being um attacked. Now, one major
advantage that Iran has that the
Americans don't have is that the
Iranians are able to calibrate their
attacks. Um, and what I mean by that is
the Americans is go and do shock and
all. They try to blow as many things as
possible. Whereas the Iranians, they
actually try to figure out what pressure
points are in the GCC. So, what they're
trying to do is they're trying to split
off the GCC from the American Empire.
They're trying to um cause instability
within these different kingdoms uh
whether it be Bahrain or uh UAE or Saudi
Arabia. Uh they're basically trying to
provoke a civil uprising against these
Gulf monarchies and they're trying to
basically uh splinter the alliance uh
because by controlling Hummus they can
say to the GCC that if you play ball
we'll let your ships uh through. That's
very appealing to the GCC because the
reality is that uh they depend on the G
on their home moves not just for um oil
exports but they also depend on the on
the for food imports as as well. Also we
have to remember that um if Iran want to
destroy the entire GC GCC it could do
so. So um uh Trump has threatening has
threatened the cement infrastructure of
Iran. Basically they destroy the
dissalination plants uh the lexure grid
and Iran's response was that if you do
so then we will destroy uh the
dissalination plants of the GCC and
destroy the oil refineries of them as
well basically causing their economies
to collapse because remember uh the GCC
require uh uh uses the desalination
plants for 60% of its freshwater supply.
uh meaning it doesn't have organic
freshwater um supply. So Iran has far
more advantages than than the United
States in this war. So for these
reasons, I actually think that from a
military perspective, um Iran has um
more advantages. From a political
perspective, it's it's night in day in
that this war is extremely unpopular in
the United States.
um about threequarters of Americans did
not support a strike against Iran. And
now that the war has started, you have
more and more Americans confused as to
the strategy and purpose of this war.
And Trump himself has failed to
articulate a clear strategy. And it
seems as though the re the rationale
behind this war changes every day. So
maybe in the beginning it was about
protest now and then it became nuclear
weapons. Um and now it's uh it's because
Israel was going to attack first and so
United and Iran was going to retaliate
against both the United States and
Israel and therefore United States had
to preempt um you know Israel's
preemptive strike. Um so from a
political perspective right now in
America it's it's very much a divided
nation whereas in Iran it's complete
opposite where the death of the
Ayatollah and also on the first day
remember uh an American tomahawk missile
struck a girl school in the south of um
Iran that killed about 170 score girls.
These are primary school girls and most
of them are actually the children of
Islamic revolution re guard members. And
so what what that has done is galvanized
nation to resist and to defend their
sovereignty because if you're Iranian,
you've so you've seen what the Americans
have done uh across the border in Iraq.
You've seen what they've done in Libya
and Syria. Um this is a war of
destruction. The Americans are hoping to
break um um Iran into ethnic archives,
what we call bulcanization
and divide and rule Iran and basically
destroy Persian civilization. And many
Iranians will not tolerate this. Um so
for the Iranians, this is a fight to the
death. For the Americans, this is a war
of choice. So from a military and
political perspective, Iran has the
advantage. And last of course is
economic where uh the American economy
is very dependent on the GCC. In fact,
you could argue that the GCC is
essentially the lynch pin of American
empire because what they do is they sell
the oil um uh in petro dollars and then
they recirculate these petro dollars
back into the American stock market. And
of course the golf marketies do that
because American provides milit military
production. But you know the first day
uh when this war began what what what we
know is that these bases these American
military bases were abandoned and in
fact uh the soldiers went changed into
civil clothes and went to hide in uh
hotels and that's why Iran was striking
these hotels
>> and so these Gulf monarchies now are
forced to uh reconsider their vaselage
to the American empire. So what we're
seeing I think is very much the collapse
of the um American empire.
>> Yeah. I mean that seems to be exactly
what what is happening. Professor Jang,
but then you know what do you believe is
uh behind the Trump administration and
the United States Empire then going all
in and continuing and saying they're
going to continue on with this war till
further notice. It seems like this is a
trap of their own making. But we know
that there are diff, you know, there's
lots of interests in war. We know the US
empire is built on war and war supposed
to make certain people rich. War is
supposed to ensure that an empire
expands. We can go on and on and on. But
what exact but this seems to be not
happening these kind of things. the
opposite is. So what then do you say
given that the American empire as you're
saying is uh collapsing from this war
why then uh continue on digging this uh
the hole of this trap deeper and deeper?
>> Right. So um I think the best
explanation for why this war started and
why this war is progressing the way it
is is a lethal toxic combination of both
hubris and desperation.
So uh let me take some time to explain
what I mean. Okay. So the very premise
of the American Empire is something
called the Mckender Heartland thesis.
And this was actually um something that
the British developed. Okay, so the
British was an island. It didn't it had
a very low population. And for it to
control the world, it had to control the
seas. So it built the world's greatest
navy. Um and it made sure that this navy
was the most dominant in the world. And
in fact, they designed the navy to be
able to defeat the next two great naval
powers combined.
And um and so the but with a navy a navy
is useless against a land power. And so
the great fear of the British uh
imperialist is that a great power where
would emerge in the Eurasian heartland.
Okay. So basically Europe and Asia and
at this time there were several
candidates that that could have emerged
and we're talking about the 18th century
by the way that could have emerged to
uni unify the Eurasian heartland and
create this continental
um trade system that would negate
British naval power. Okay. So the
candidates were uh the Ottoman Empire,
uh the French, the Germans and the
Russians. These four great powers. Um
and that's what led ultimately to the
Napoleonic wars. Okay, seven wars fought
between France and uh the British and
their allies. And you can actually see
the NPC wars as as ultimately an
economic trade war in that the Poland
wanted to create a continental trade
system and the British had and the
British uh refused to let him do so
because that would mean the collapse of
the British economy. Um and so the
British basically had an infinite
printing machine called the Bank of
England. They financed uh Europe to
fight against Napoleon seven times and
they lost six times but ultimately they
won and they had and they had no choice
because the British economy like the
American economy is essentially a Ponzi
scheme and so and so they have to keep
on financing until they beat Napoleon.
After Napoleon was defeated, uh Britain
um became the global hedgeimon and then
it focused its attention on trying to
divide and conquer Germany and Russia.
So in the 19th century uh Britain
engaged in something called the great
game with Russia where they fought for
Central Asia because again Britain
cannot afford for Russia to unify uh the
heartland because if Russia did that it
could build a railroad system so that
all trade um could exist could just
happen within the continent and then
extend to Africa as well as the Middle
East. Um and in of course in the 20th
century uh Britain and Germany fought
two great wars and America came in to
save Britain in the end and prevent
Germany from unifying the uh heartland.
Okay. So that's the main idea uh behind
the American Empire and it's still true
today. And um after the Soviet Union
fell uh America had this unipolan moment
where it could extend its empire through
throughout the world and this empire
came to an end actually in 2022 when
Putin invaded Ukraine and with um Russia
essentially winning this war in Ukraine.
There's a great fear that Russia, Iran
and China would come together as
partners uh in breaks and then they
could unify the heartland economically
and then extend to Europe uh Middle East
and um Africa basically bricks plus and
then they could just dump the US dollar
and right now the United States is
sitting on $40 trillion in debt and if
and it's a Ponzi scheme so if other
nations stop buying US dollars, then uh
America would be left holding a bag um
and then the bomb would explode in their
face, the American economy would
collapse and you would see a revolution
on streets in America. So in other
words, America didn't really have a
choice but to prevent Iran, Russia, and
China from forming a heartland alliance.
Now the problem with an empire is that
once you become desperate, you make
silly decisions and the reason why is
hubris. Okay? uh the belief that you are
invincible and America developed hubris
primarily because for the past 20 years
America could do whatever wanted in the
Middle East. So in 2003 it took America
exactly two weeks to steam o steamroll
over um Iraq and um they did it so with
very little casualties and they did so
with u massive political support in the
United States. And so America just
believed it was invincible. And this
sense of inevitability and invincibility
um cemented itself throughout the Middle
East uh because America um even though
it caused a lot of havoc and
destruction, it was still triumphant in
Libya, in Syria, uh throughout the
Middle East basically. And so from their
perspective, what's the difference
between, you know, Iraq and Iran, right?
Same name, just one other difference.
And so that's the idea of hubris. And
this hubris um basically got um
basically blinded Donald Trump with with
arrogance um in Venezuela because
remember back in on in January January
3rd double force swept into um Carac uh
Caracus and basically kidnapped Maduro
without and there was no American
casualties. It was a miracle of the
American military. Um, it was almost
like as though God wielded. Um, and so
that made Trump extremely arrogant and
that probably convinced him that he
could do anything he wanted because he
had the most powerful military in the
the world. And so um um so he basically
ordered the invasion the attack on Iran
believing that decapitation strike the
in the first day um would cause the
regime to collapse because it was so uh
hated by the people. Remember in January
there were also these protests in Iran.
So um it was a severe miscalculation and
it was caused by again a lethal
combination of both hubris and
desperation. Huberous in that the empire
thought it was invincible, desperation
in that it had no choice in the matter
but to start this war in order to
maintain its hegemony throughout the
world.
Then, Professor Jang, uh, will this,
we've heard some rumblings in Wall
Street Journal about a possible land
invasion, US troops being sent to try to
seize the coastline in the midst of
especially the Straight of Hormuz
crisis. Uh, at the same time though, you
have the US Navy saying they can't
escort tankers. You have uh reports that
have not been confirmed. the USS Lincoln
needing to retreat because they got hit.
The USS Gerald Ford uh having mysterious
fires and of course the tankers that
were downed over Iraq just in the last
24 hours. But do you see uh US troops uh
uh coming uh to Iran to invade? And if
so uh game theory that for us, will you?
So what people forget is that in 2003
uh when America did shock and all there
was tremendous military push back
against the doctrine of shock and all.
Basically, um Donald Ronfield, who was
the secretary of defense at that time,
and his um uh assistant Paul Woleritz
believed that America could go in with
air power with very little ground troops
and they could very quickly decapitate
the regime by destroying its command and
control centers.
And America could do this cheaply and
quickly. And the entire joint chiefs of
staff, the generals who knew what they
were doing were against this plan. They
thought it was insane. They fought went
against um centuries of milit military
doctrine. From their perspective, you
have to fight the war conservatively and
to win. You just can't gamble with uh
war. So I believe at that time um they
went in with 100,000 troops and the
joint chief of staff actually initially
asked for half a million troops because
that was what they believed they needed
to win this war. and uh it became a
political uh dog fight and ultimately
Brumsfield and Wolfitz won and their
gamble paid off massive dividends and
ever since then America has um adopted
its shock and all policy. Now the
problem with shock and all is that
people forget but at that time 2003 Iraq
didn't have any ear defense. Okay. It
didn't have any way to defend against
American invasion. And part it's and
that was partly because by that time
Iraq had suffered over 10 years of
American sanctions. So the economy was
depleted. Uh the people were in low
morale and the soldiers were not really
paid. Okay? So they didn't really have
that much air defense. And then when
Saddam Hussein was um basically advised
to get a defense, his response was,
"Listen, if the Americans came after me,
then they would eliminate the main
adversary to Iran in the Middle East. So
why would they do that? That would be
just be insane." And honestly, if they
came, I couldn't really defend myself
either. Okay, so that was his thinking.
was extremely logical and rational, but
unfortunately the Americans are were not
logical and rational because they're an
empire. So, um people forget that 2003
was an anomaly. It was not a real war.
Um but this war in Iran is a real war.
And in a real war, you need to use
ground troops. Why? Because ear defense
is meant to
defend against the air. So the way you
counter air defense is actually with
ground troops. Okay? And in a in a real
war actually the ground troops are the
bread and butter. The infantry are the
bread and butter um of your military. So
the Americans have been living in a
fantasy world for the past 20 years and
now they need to adapt to the real world
if they are to win this war. Now, I
understand that then ground invasion
would be political suicide in United
States because the war is not very
popular. And quite honestly, Donald
Trump would need to institute a national
draft in order to get the 500,000 combat
soldiers that he would need for a ground
invasion. And by the way, half a million
is just the bare minimum. You probably
want two million troops if you are to
fight this war properly. Okay? So half
half a million is is what they are
proposing. and they would need national
draft in order to get this number of
troops. And you you can imagine the
political opposition in United States if
that were to happen. Plus, what most
military analysts would tell you is that
America is not equipped to fight Iran
because Iran is a mountain fortress and
America doesn't have the logistics
chains, the manufactured capacity uh and
an inventory to launch a multi-war uh
sorry, a multi-year
uh ground invasion of Iran from multiple
vectors. Okay, so we're talking uh you
would need to control the servos and
then you would need to come in from the
east, the west, and then north. Um so
it's a very complicated thing and this
would take about a two years to actually
plan properly but in these two years
Iran would get enough assistance from
the Russians, the Chinese and others in
order to properly prepare for this
ground invasion and therefore you need
to do it as soon as possible before Iran
can fully recover from this um from from
this war. Okay? So a ground invasion
wouldn't work but they have to do it if
they actually win this war. Now I
understand okay there are people who say
why not just declare a victory and go
home and then end this war it's not as
simple as that. Okay
this when a war starts war developed its
own momentum. So, let me play out for
you using game theory what happened if
Donald Trump were to say, "You know
what? We got we got the we got the
Ayatollah. We've destroyed their nuclear
weapons program. We've destroyed their
obstics program. We've made the world
safe for um for Israel. Let's just go
home, guys. Goodbye. See you later."
Okay, here's what would happen. Okay,
first thing that would happen is Iran
would say to the GCC nations, "Hey, man.
Uh the Americans came and destroyed our
nation. Most of our civilian military
infrastructure is gone. We need repar
reparations. You either pay us
reparations or we'll come and invade you
guys. Okay. And GC nation is like but we
didn't do anything. And the Iranians
will be like, well, you know what?
You've been hosting American bases for
the longest time. Also, you they use
your airspace to attack us. Also, you're
the guys who are financing this war
because of your investments in the
American economy. And so, if if the GCC
nations refuse to pay repar reparations
and Iran would cause civil uprisings
um in these um nations, remember these
are unpopular corrupt monarchies in the
GCC. Um Ban has basically fallen um and
everyone else could fall as well. uh UAE
is uh can be easily taken out. And so
what these GCC nations would then say to
Iran is let's make a deal. And the deal
is very simple. We have $4 trillion in
our sovereign war funds. We're going to
help you finance the rebuilding of your
nation. And also when our ships go for
the Stra of Hummus, we'll pay you a tax
because now you are the defender of the
straight of Homus. Okay? So that's the
GCC. Basically the GCC which was a lynch
pin of the American empire now trans
transfers over to Iran and they become
the client states of Iran. That's the
first major consequence. The second
major consequence is um if you are Japan
and South Korea for the longest time
you've been buying US treasuries at an
inflated price you're basically paying a
tax a tribute to American empire in
order to ensure that American empire
defends you. Well, you just saw what
happened um in the Middle East. So,
you're like, why am I doing this? Why am
I hosting these American bases? When
when a war starts, these guys, these
50,000 or 100,000 American soldiers will
just fly home. Uh so, first of all, get
out of here, guys. We don't we don't
watch anymore. Second of all, we're not
going to buy US treasuries because
clearly um uh the United States is not a
re reliable ally. Okay? So South Korea
and Japan would remmilitarize
and basically become much more
self-sufficient economies and stop
buying US treasuries. Um then you would
have um Europe which would which which
would then be like why are we fighting
this war in Ukraine again? Oh wait a
minute we're fighting this war because
Americans asked us to fight this war. In
fact the Americans asked us to pay 5% of
our GDP in order to finance this war in
Ukraine. Also, Americans are asking us
to draft our soldiers, which is
political suicide in our countries. It
might cause a civil uprising. Um, but we
have no choice because there are lots
and lots of American bases in Europe.
But after you saw what happened in the
Middle East and in Southeast Asia, then
you're like, you know what? We don't
actually need these American bases. So,
why don't you guys go home? Okay. So,
then American Empire is just kicked out
of everywhere. They're forced to close
most of their uh um global bases, and
you're like, "Okay, fine. We'll just go
home." is is not what Trump said in the
first place. America first. Make America
great again. Forget the rest of the
world. Let's focus on the Western
Hemisphere. Again, it's not that simple
because remember, America is a Ponzi
scheme that depends on the rest of the
world buying US dollars. And as long as
the US dollars buy, sorry, as long as
the rest of the world buys US dollars,
the Ponzi scheme can continue. Once uh
Japan, China, South Korea, Europe, the
GCC stop buying US dollars, what
happens? You have economic collapse. Uh
and once you have economic collapse, you
have civil discontent. We're talking
about something much much worse than the
great depression. Take the great
depression and magnify by 100 times, you
come close to the calamity uh that is
ahead uh for America. And so uh it's
very possible that if you were to
retreat uh from the from the GCC, you
would cause a chain of events that would
lead to blue revolution in America. And
so if you are the elite in America, your
options are wait for the revolution to
happen sooner or later or send in ground
troops with a hope that you know you
pray to God enough then you can uh
maintain your empire.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, uh I wanted to then
get to how you believe then given that
these are the possibilities how uh it
will actually transpire professor Johnny
especially in terms of the impact on the
world uh with this war because you know
we had already been talking about on
this show for many years now uh the
emergence of a new world order that is
not dominated by US hijgemony. uh how do
you see this war and its aftermath um
affecting the the wider world given that
it's not only a regional war war but
it's become a global war a world war in
many respects and you've talked about uh
this being a not just a prelude but
actually a a part of a world war II
scenario that we are in
>> right so people don't really appreciate
how unique and unsustainable the
American unipolar moment was think of
this where just an average American,
okay, and we're just talking about like
like a middle class American. Well, he
can have any day of the week, okay, for
breakfast, avocados from Mexico, uh,
white wines from Chile, uh, he can book
a flight on the website and very cheaply
fly to Maldis for a week-l long vacation
and just US dollars to pay for
everything.
um he can go to Europe for the summer uh
for the internet. He can communicate
with people from all around the world.
And this is unsustainable because
a lot of it depends on people's belief
that the American Empire is invincible
and therefore have no choice but to be a
vassel to this empire. And that's what
sustains this unipolar moment. But now
that you have this aura of inevitability
and immutability collapse uh punctured
by this war in Iran, then people no
longer believe in the American empire.
And so what you'll see are three major
trends happen in the next 5 to 10 years.
And quite honestly, the nations that are
uh most willing to embrace these three
trends will emerge from the classical
empire uh the most vibrant. Okay. And
these three major trends are number one
deindustrialization and deurbanization.
Okay. So what I mean by that is that it
is silly that we have so many mega
cities around the world. Uh think about
how many cities with 10 million plus
people there are around the world. And
it's silly and stupid because we depend
on food to uh live. And these people in
the cities, they're not growing food. um
and and where they're getting food is uh
importing this food uh from overseas or
internally. Okay. So you have basically
a specialization of agriculture
throughout the world where basically
just one nation just does one uh um uh
one cash corp um you know growing
bananas or avocados whatever okay but
that's just really silly to do. Um, and
you but you can do this as long as you
have cheap oil because cheap oil allows
you the fertilizers to grow food but
also cheap oil allows you to transport
this food throughout the world. Um, but
again it's all premised on cheap oil.
What happens when the cheap oil goes
away? Well, you have food supply issues.
Okay. So these 10 million people in the
cities doing whatever you know whether
it's um cryptocurrency scams or gambling
on poly market or uh engaging in uh
derivatives um creating derivatives um
creating AI um you know like like it's
all just useless and silly. People need
to grow food and so that we can eat.
Okay. So if you're if you are really
into AI, guess what? You're going to be
really really screwed without access to
cheap energy. So stop this AI stupidity
and go back to growing food. Okay? So
that means getting people out of the
cities and back to the farmland to grow
food to create more sustainable supply
chains. And again, you have to do this
or your people going to starve. I'm I'm
tell I'm telling this this entire world,
okay? Give up your delusions about AI.
It does nothing. It'll get you nowhere.
Make sure your people have access to
food and water. Okay, that's the first
major trend. The industrial
uh Professor John, it seems like we've
uh lost you here. Uh you said uh make
sure to prepare for to to grow food,
focus on food. Uh but you are frozen. If
you can hear me, uh maybe you could
refresh your uh browser. Um as you have
uh frozen, I will also Oh, there you
are. All right. Yeah, sorry.
>> You're back. So, so I mean I have a
basic point which is like the
industrialization and urbanization
require cheap energy and once you lose
access to cheap energy, you have to
worry about having s sustainable food
supply networks. That means you have to
move people back to the to the
countryside to grow food in order to
feed your your population. Okay, that
has to be done. Okay, that that's my
first point.
My second um trend, the second trend
that's very important is the idea of
remilitarization.
Meaning that in the future people are
going to fight over resources. And so
you need to remmilitarize your
population. And what this means
ultimately is the return of nationalism
and in some examples
um for the greater good is through
nationalism. There are some other
nations that will become theocracies uh
the embrace of religious faith. Okay.
But like the idea of this like this
multicultural,
multipolar, sorry, multicultural, global
diversity, DI, all this nonsense, it has
to go away. Just just throw it out.
Okay? No more diversity, no more
multiculturalism. Just focus on who we
are as a people and the need for us to
be cohesive in order to defend our
nation. Okay? So re remilitarization,
the return of nationalism and the um
third major uh trend is the breaking up
of these of of the global economy and
the creation of merkantile
trade networks. Okay. And that could be
cooperation among certain nations and
that's what we should see in Europe uh
where Europe becomes its own trading
block and no longer engages with the
rest of the world. But it can also mean
that a certain nation becomes dominant
in a region and post its will in that
region. So I see um Israel achieving
something called the greater Israel
project and being able to control trade
uh throughout the Mediterranean um the
Middle East and Africa. Um in East Asia
there'd be competition between South
Korea, North Korea, Vietnam, Japan and
China for resources
and um and they need to create um their
own independent supply chains especially
Japan um Japan is in this sort of
scenario the most disadvantaged because
they don't have uh enough resources to
fuel their uh advanced manufacturing
economy.
And so we could see u a very aggressive
remarized Japan over the next uh few
months. In fact, Prime Minister Taki has
voiced tremendous support for this
Israel US war against Iran and she's
promised to send missiles and um
ammunitions in defense sorry over to the
Middle East to support this war. Okay.
So so so these are the three major
trends that we should see over next few
months. um nations adopting uh more
de-industrialized policies,
um nations uh adop embracing nationalism
and then also uh nations trying to
create their own independent uh supply
chains. And the irony of course is the
the nations that benefit the most from
globalization will be the ones that
actually have the toughest toughest time
adapting to the new world. That includes
of course um United States, China, uh
Germany. Um yeah,
>> I wanted to ask you uh Professor Jang
about uh the you you made a comment
about greater Israel and the attempt to
achieve it. Um what do where do you see
that now given that uh Iran doesn't seem
like it's on the verge of collapse. It
seems like its government is very much
intact and uh now even the collective
west is admitting this and I think
Europe is on the phone with Iran right
now trying to get a deal to move their
cargo and their commercial vessels
through the straight of Hormuz. Um but
also Israel is in heavy fighting with
Hezbollah and uh part of the greater
Israel project will also include Iraq
and we see the resistance downing
refueling tankers. So there's certainly
opposition to this and we haven't even
gone into Yemen yet uh with what could
happen if the Babe is closed. So uh what
do you make of where the greater Israel
project is right now and how that will
take shape in the days and weeks to
come?
Okay. So, Israel is a very
sorry. So, Israel is a very difficult
nation to understand because of their
theology, because of their understanding
of their place in the world. They call
themselves God's chosen people. Okay?
So, from an Israeli perspective, okay,
if you are a religious extremist, this
war is is going according to God's plan
because how do you achieve the greater
Israel project? Well, you achieve the
greater Israel project by removing
America from the Middle East. Uh, and
you achieve the greatest Israel project
by basically destroying the GCC. Um, and
and ultimately um to achieve the Greater
Israel project, you you eventually have
to go after um Turkey and Egypt as well
because the greater Israel, if you see a
map, um it actually extends from the
Nile to the Euphrates. Iran actually is
actually not part of greater Israel.
Okay? So in other words, these religious
extremists want this war in the Middle
East in order to um move forward to
accelerate um the greater Israel project
which they believe is what God promised
them through their ancestor Abraham.
Okay. So in other words, from an Israeli
perspective, your real objectives
in this war is not to defeat Iran. Okay?
You want to weaken Iran, but it's not
really feasible for you as small nation
to defeat Iran. Okay. So, what are your
real military objectives that you can
actually say? Well, first of all, it's
to u destroy the American empire and
force Americans out of the Middle East.
It's to destroy Saudi Arabia because
actually part of Saudi Arabia is is part
of the greater Israel project. And to
drag Turkey into this war because the
south of of Anatolia, Turkey is actually
part of the greater Israel project as
well. So that's what you want to do. And
and if this war drags on and the
Americans sends in ground troops, then
you are then you're actually um
accelerating God's plan. Um also what
people don't recognize is that this
destruction in Israel, this these
religious extremists think that it is
the will of God. Okay. So where are the
Iranians striking Tel Aviv? Where are
they not striking really? Jerusalem.
There's a huge difference between Tel
Aviv and Jerusalem. People don't really
appreciate
>> Oh, sorry. Sorry that was a mistake.
>> People don't really appreciate the
political dynamic in uh Tel Aviv.
Jerusalem and T sorry people don't
really appreciate the political dynamic
in Israel. Tel Aiv and Jerusalem are two
opposing centers of gravity in Israel.
Tell Tel Aviv is the western looking,
the open, the cosmopolitan, the secular,
the democratic
um version or face of Israel. Jerusalem
is the inward-looking, the um um
religious, theocratic, a conservative um
face of Israel. And guess what? They
hate each other. And if Tel Aviv were to
be destroyed, okay, meaning like the
open cosmopolitan democratic sector,
Israel would be destroyed in this war.
Good. Because that is God's will. God
doesn't want these um you know open
western eur western uh Jews in Israel.
Um he wants them to repent. He wants
them to engage in redemption. And in the
Jewish theology, redemption is only
possible through pain, suffering. Okay?
You need to commit sin uh in order to
force God to punish you and then you
engage in a long process of
self-reflection
um self revitalization in order to fully
embrace God. Okay? So in other words,
these religious extremists are hoping to
use this war to inflict so much damage
and pain on
uh secular Israel that they see the they
see the error of their ways and they
embrace God fully. And if you don't do
so, well then go away. Go back to
Europe. Go back to America. Who cares?
Okay. But Israel, they want they want
Israel become a theocracy uh because of
this war. So I I know it's hard to
understand uh because most of us are not
religious and when we hear this we think
it's all insane but unfortunately right
now the religious fanatics have control
over uh the national security operatives
the military of Israel and they want to
use this war in order to bring the
Jewish people closer to God. and they
believe that by doing so this will um
accelerate the coming of the Messiah and
usher in the messianic age. So from
their perspective it's all going to
going according to plan um and they have
some surprises in store for the world
for example um the Actic mosque which I
think will may be destroyed in this war.
Well, also, Professor Jang, the US
military has been infected by this um
kind of uh uh uh religious extremism. Uh
you've probably seen the reports of 200
plus complaints uh from the military
religious freedom foundation uh by US
troops uh saying that they were told
that uh this war was all part of God's
divine plan and they were to they there
were multiple references to the book of
revelation referring to Armageddon and
the imminent return of Jesus Christ
because of this war. So uh you know I
think a lot of people are interested
first John hearing your uh take on uh
how this uh rel religious extremism we
see and this is when we talk Israel and
of course the collective west it's
getting worse and worse uh contrary to
how people view Iran actually um
and I'm wondering how you see that
affecting not just this war but also the
world as these changes is the end of
unipolar dominance by the United States
uh really becomes much more apparent
from this war and of course uh you know
in the coming days and weeks.
>> Right? So um I've always argued that
this war is esquetological. Okay?
Meaning you can't really explain this
war from a purely geopolitical lens.
Yes, I do know that I spent the early
part of this discussion talking about
why empire needs to engage in war. But
you know there are alternatives to um
what they're doing. Okay. So the first
alternative is just become friends with
Iran. You know remove the sanctions uh
return to the nuclear deal the Obama era
nuclear deal and engage in trade with
Iran. And look the Iranians are pumatic
people. They would welcome American
investment. They would welcome the
opportunity to sell their oil to
America. Okay that's your first option.
But if you don't want to do that option,
then you can also choose a strategy of
economic strangulation, meaning that you
basically embargo Iran. You know, Iran
sells most of its oil to China and
that's a shadow fleet. Well, you can
embargo uh Iran because if you just look
at the map, the American military base
is everywhere, right? So, you have
options. the worst thing you can do is
actually go and attack Iran because then
you find yourself in this sort of
situation where now you're losing the
war and you're forced to send in ground
troops if you are to win this war and
we've already discussed why that would
be suicidal both militarily,
economically and politically. So then
the question then is why do they pick
the worst option and um it's
esqueological where there are people in
the United States um and these are
secret societies and these are different
secret societies who who believe this
they believe that a war in the Middle
East once it's started it will create a
ser a chain of events that will lead
eventually to the end of the world the
end times and this and this and for
different secret societies this could
mean different things. Okay. So for the
Freemasons it would mean the creation of
Paka a one world government and the
coming of an AI surveillance state um
where Jerusalem is the center of the
world. Okay. Then you have these
messianic Jews um called um the Shabbat
Lubich movement and there are others as
well. Okay. But the most famous who
believe that um this war will initi
initiate something called the war of
Gaul and Magog which is really the end
the final battle of humanity where the
world basically attacks Israel and this
will force the return sorry the coming
of the Messiah um the intervention of
God basically and the coming of the meic
age uh where God can live will live with
his people uh the Jews. Uh and then the
Christian Zionists um believe that this
war will um initiate the go war of Gog
and Mog and then Jesus will return to
save Israel from its enemies and then
all Christians who believe in Jesus will
be raptured up into heaven before uh
Jesus ushers in the millennium, the
messianic age and then you have the
final day of judgment. Okay. So, I
understand this is sort of like bonkers,
but I mean most people in this world
happen to be religious. Uh, Christian
Zionism is about a quarter of the
population of America. You know, you
have this uh movement called Christians
United for Israel, 7 million members,
and their only um goal, 7 million
members, their only goal is to ensure
that American politicians
help bring about the end the end of
days. Um and these are the people who
actually are funding these West Bank
settlements which are clearly against
international law. Right? So you have
these all these um Israeli settlers in
the West Bank who don't actually work
and they have like large families. It's
all being funded by Christians United
for Israel and other Christian Zionists.
So this plan has been in motion for
decades. I would even I would argue even
for centuries. Okay. So they want to
usher in the end of days. And so there
are certain things that that will happen
that will surprise people and it makes
absolutely no sense but it's all
according to their theology um their
esquetology. Okay. So what will happen
eventually is the Alexic moss will be
destroyed um and in fact there's been
discussions on social media how this
will happen. Basically the idea is okay
for the past few years they've been
conducting archeological digs under the
Alexic moss which which is the third
holiest site in Islam by the way and so
the foundations of the Alexic Mahas are
very unstable and so basically if an
Iranian missile goes astray and we we
won't actually know if it's Iranian
missile but of course we blame on
Iranians then the there'll be control
demolition of the ice mos okay so so
again look it's all speculation it's all
rumors but if it were to happen then you
will know that it's all for
esquetological purposes. Um and um and
and of course um and also like this is
hard for people to understand but
anti-semitism the rise of anti-semitism
in the western world is also part of
this es esquetology because in both the
Jewish and Christian esquetological
understanding of things the Jews must
return to Jerusalem to seek redemption
to seek repetit uh so sorry to seek u
the love of of God to unify with with
God. And that basically means bring
bringing the Jewish diaspora back to
Jerusalem. Now, as you know, most Jews,
many Jews in the Western world live very
nice lives. Uh they're very successful.
>> Oh, you froze. Uh Professor John, you
said they're very successful
if you come back.
>> Yeah. So, so yeah. So, they're
successful and then they won't come back
voluntarily. Well, then you make them.
And again, I know this sounds crazy, but
please remember this war in Iran is
crazy. It makes absolutely no sense why
the Americans are fighting the war they
the way the way they are. And it it and
like honestly, it doesn't seem as though
Trump and his people really care. And
you know, their response to this growing
unpopularity
um of this war in America is maybe to
institute a national draft. You know,
there's talk of deploying the National
Guard to quell unrest uh throughout the
um throughout America. You know, like
Trump's cabinet has basically moved on
to American military bases. And the
people that would be most responsible
for National GeForce
No uh Gnome, they've all moved to
American military bases. And why would
they do that? Okay. So, it seems as
though something has been being prepared
for America.
>> Well, uh, Professor Jang, you know
what's what you're describing here. I'm
wondering how it clashes with capital
then because we know that finance cap,
we know that the military complex, they
have very I wouldn't call them rational
given everything that we talked about so
far with how this war has transpired. Uh
but there are I think uh understandable
uh uh uh disagreements and you know
irreconcilable contradictions that they
have with uh the Iranian government uh
whether it's uh you know uh wanting to
uh maintain hegemony and ensure as you
said earlier that Russia China Iran
cannot uh unite at a political economic
and military level and we could go on
and on and on of the straight of four
moves for example to have control of
that to be able to ensure uh you know
so-called freedom of navigation aka
dominance of all trade routes to cut off
China and anyone uh else uh who needs to
be dominated uh in to ensure that their
trade routes uh are directed by the US
and therefore will benefit US financial
interests. So how does this development
that you're describing clash or align or
some or both? How help us understand uh
why there is because in many ways what
you're describing could very well clash
with it. Uh so how does how does it all
come together. Okay. So unfortunately um
the estology of these religious
extremists and transational capital
their interests are aligned. Okay. So uh
let me explain why. So this esquetology
comes from these occultists who spent
their entire lives um reading the Bible
and trying to interpret divine um
providence uh and divine intention in in
the Bible. Okay. So they feel feel as
though this Bible is is actually the
words of God and God has laid out this
plan in the Bible. So if we're able to
interpret this code properly, then we
have then we have an understanding of
God's plan and therefore we can enact it
in our world to accelerate the return of
God to to our world. And famous
occultists in the past include um Isaac
Newton. Um people don't appreciate that
he spent most of his life actually
studying the Bible and you know him
creating the laws of physics was
actually just a um function or a side
function of his intense study of of the
Bible because he's he's trying to
understand the mind of God. Okay.
Another very famous occultist is Sab
Zevi. Um a modern-day occultist that
just recently passed away but who's
extremely influential is named Rabbi
Sneren who was the global leader of
something called the Shabbat Lug
movement. Okay, so we don't actually
need to know these people. We we just
know that there are these people in the
shadows who are planning all this. Okay,
now if you're not a cultist, you're
interested in the movement of the stars,
your movement, you're interested in the
grand scheme of humanity and therefore
you have insight to certain historical
patterns that emerge. Okay, so the world
that we're living in um the patterns
that are emerging, the collapse of
empire, this is how all empires collapse
and this something that cultists
understand. Okay. But from their
perspective, this isn't just game theory
or this isn't just uh the nature of
empires. For for them, they believe it
is actually the intention of God. Okay?
So um so from their perspective, you can
actually change events, but what you can
do is accelerate events, right? So if an
empire is collapsed, and these empires
usually about 20 20 years, 20 years to
collapse, um that would create
tremendous human suffering, right? Look,
look, look at the collapse of the Roman
Empire and how many wars, how much
bloodshed was um was conducted because
of the collapse of empire and the
collapse of the empire led to the dark
ages, right? About a thousand years when
Western civilization had to reconstruute
itself. Well,
why can't you accelerate the class
empire in order to build a better world?
Wouldn't that be um a much better way of
doing things? Yes, you c you cause a lot
of pain and death in the beginning in
the short term, but it's long-term gain,
right? Short-term pain for long-term
gain. That's like literally how they
think. Okay, so that's how these
esquetologists or cultists think. Now,
let's look at transnational capital.
Okay, and Jeffrey Epstein, if you read
his emails, he was actually very
interested in geopolitical events
because he understood that from
geopolitical chaos, you can make a lot
of money, right? Right. So the famous
saying is when there's blood on the
streets buy. Okay. So Jeffrey Epstein
was going around getting conf
confidential information from people
like Peter Menston who was the um oh
sorry is Menson and and anyway he was
getting conf confidential information
from a lot of powerful people around the
world in order to better gauge how
geopolitical events uh would map out.
Okay. Um, so transition capital is
interested in war, interested in
destruction, interested in chaos because
that's the best time to buy. Okay, so
let's imagine that there's this war
raging in the Middle East. Let's just
say that there's this uh civil war
raging in America and there's a lot of
destruction. That's great for you as
transnational capital because now you
can sweep in and buy resources for
really cheap, right? Um and the faster
this d disruption happens the more
profit you can generate in uh at the end
at the end of the day. So what we're
seeing in the world is a massive
alliance like this grand alliance
between the military-industrial complex
which benefits more these esquetologists
these occultists who want to accelerate
the end of the world and these
transnational capitalists who believe
that when the world burns then is the
best opportunity to buy. Otherwise, I
mean, if you trust your capital and
you're sitting on billions billions of
dollars, what do you what do you buy?
Because US dollar is a scam, uh, real
estate is a scam, cryptocurrency is a
scam. Well, you know, if you destroy the
world, now you can buy up these
resources, water rights, uh, mining
rights for really cheap. Um, and during
the re rebuilding process, you can make
a lot of money, right? So, so, so, so
that's how these things work.
Yeah. Well, uh, Professor Jang, I wanted
to then ask you, uh, we're getting, uh,
reports, uh, that, uh, you know, the
United States, the empire, it's going
through great lengths to try to mitigate
the massive consequences of this war.
Um, you know, they've, uh, lifted
sanctions temporarily on Russia. They
flooded they've tried to flood the
market with reserves from 32 countries a
part of the IAEA.
None of it is reducing prices actually
in the last several days. Uh it's it's
nearly risen back to $100 a barrel and
the trend actually is is just up and up
and up. Uh reports are that this crisis
energy crisis is worse than the 1970s
crisis already by a factor of two. Um
and it's just started. What happens uh
uh Professor John, when Iran saying that
our oil will be going to $200 a barrel,
what happens then when it does? Because
everything that we talked about up until
this point, including what you just
said, uh will play a factor in this, I I
assume. So, what happens then? Because
that's that's a major economic crisis
that uh um you know, I don't think we've
really faced uh before or at least to
this magnitude.
>> Yeah. So look, the reality is that the
old world, the world of global uh
globalization, it's dying and it's it's
and this war is going to kill it.
There's actually no going back to the
old world. And we're heading to and
we're heading towards a new world of
chaos, uh instability, resource,
scarcity, which is really how humans
have lived most of their lives. So if
you just go back to 1930s
um and look at what happened 1930s, well
probably the same thing will happen um
in our world um over the next few years.
So in the short term what governments
are going to do is they're they're going
to try to compensate for the lack of
access to cheap energy and basically so
in Southeast Asia we're seeing work from
home. We're seeing the implementation of
4day work weeks. eventually they'll move
to lockdowns uh very similar to COVID a
as well because the reality is that
without cheap energy it's impossible for
the modern nation state to sustain the
populations that that they have right um
you can't feed tens of millions of
people based on food imports and cheap
energy so um u these nations are going
to struggle and you will see lockdowns
you will see food rationing
uh throughout the world. They have
actually no choice in the matter. These
airlines are going to have to close
down. People cannot fly around the world
whenever they want anymore. It's too
expensive and it's and it's too
pointless uh to uh to do so. So,
um prices will go will skyrocket uh es
especially for plane fairs, especially
for meat. Um and so that's a short term.
Um in the midterm um you will see
conflicts throughout the world. So this
could include civil unrest. Um this
could include political revolutions. Uh
because remember these governments
around the world most of them are not
democratic and most of them are
extremely unpopular and most of them are
actually sustained by the power of
American empire.
um especially uh in this in Islamic
world um especially in South America.
And so once American empire fades and
American empire is not able to provide
uh a material lifestyle then the revol
the population is going to revolt and
you will see the rise primarily of like
right-wing nationalist movements and
we're already seeing that in Europe. um
um and and and I and that's just going
to be a natural trend. Um in the long
term, you will see um massive
um remunerization
and a massive restructuring of society.
Okay. So, one thing that these nations
need to resolve is the aging crisis
especially in Europe, especially in
Southeast Asia, South Korea, Japan.
Whichever nation is able to resolve the
aging crisis as soon as possible will
come out of the coming chaos the most
vibrant nation. And I think that there's
one nation in the world that I think
actually has a solution to the aging
crisis and that's Japan. Why? Because
the aging crisis in Japan is the most
salient. Uh it could destroy the
economy. And so what I think will happen
is that Japan will institute a national
euthanasia program. So if you're over
80, um you will volunteer to um you you
know Yeah. But but but but but I'm sorry
this is hard. Okay. But I mean like the
world that we're going into, we have to
we have to really plan ahead and imagine
the darkest possibilities. Um so so yeah
it's not a pretty picture.
>> Yeah. What's so interesting I was just
looking at the rankings. Uh two of the
biggest countries uh I guess we could
count Gana as food self-sufficient. It's
on the rankings internationally but
China and Vietnam are two and three and
the rest of the countries you can see
very low. US western countries very very
very low. So in the hardest of times uh
it'll be very difficult for the
collective west to be able to sustain
itself. And I think that's why we see
too profess and the collective west US
this kind of extremism that you say
complements so well the wararm mongering
the desperate attempts to uh basically
blow up the world are are so salient. Um
because I I I do think that there is
this um there is this real urge from uh
those who uh control Washington. Some
people call them the Epstein class to
ensure that uh that they are covered
that their that their behinds are
covered as things continue to uh spiral
for for the system that they uh control.
So, Professor John, any final comments?
Anything you want to say about the um
you know about the Iran situation, the
global situation as as it relates to it
uh that we might not have said so far.
>> Right. So the western nations, Europe,
North America are the ones who are who
will suffer the most in this age of
tribulation. And a lot of the reason why
is that for the past 50 years, these
nations have the best lives. Like if
you're a baby boomer, you had the best
possible life. You probably you probably
live better than the Roman emperor. Um
so it was just a very unsustainable
um lifestyle. And these baby boomers,
they're clinging on to empire because
it's empire that gave them all these
worldly benefits. And they're leaving a
terrible legacy for their children and
their grandchildren. And quite honestly,
they don't they don't seem to care.
People don't really appreciate the
impact of baby boomers on imperial
policy. Basically, baby boomers are
like, you know what, I have another 5,
10, 20 years um left. I want to make
sure that I'm enjoying the world and
that means I want the American empire to
um to keep on going. Okay. So, so a lot
of it is driven by this demographic, the
baby boomers and their children, their
grandchildren, basically us. Okay. We're
going to inherit a really screwed up
world. And if we seek to live to to
replicate the lifestyle of the baby
boomers uh which is materialistic,
selfish, utitarian uh we will destroy
the world and will destroy us in the
process. So right now the world needs to
have a spiritual awakening and abandon
the consumerism,
the materialism, the individualism of
the baby boomer generation of the
American empire which has led us to this
moment and really ask yourselves what is
meaningful,
what is what gives us pleasure, what
makes us happy and the answer of course
is family and community and purpose. So
in this age of tribulation,
those who are most able to survive it
are those who commit themselves to the
betterment of humanity basically by
helping um your neighbors by being an
open, generous, and kind person. You
don't have to take a cruise uh vacation
every summer. You don't have to vacation
in the Maldes. You don't have to have
avocado every single day. But what you
do need, what you really want is to love
your children and to teach your children
to be kind, open, and generous people.
What you what really gives you happiness
and joy is to help your neighbor in
need, to see others in need and
contribute your life altruistically to
their improvement. So this is a turning
point in humanity and those that cling
on to the materialistic selfish
individualistic life will be the first
to
um fall into depression. Uh and those
who embra who are incapable of a
spiritual awakening will thrive in in
this new world.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, Professor Chang, it
was uh great to have you back on the
show. So, we'll have to do it again soon
as things transpire. We'll head out of
here together. I want to thank everybody
who watched today uh and who gave a
super chat who became members. I can
pull those up really quickly as I tell
you that I have both uh Professor Jang's
Substack and his YouTube channel in the
video description below so you can check
those out when we are done here. I also
have all the places to support this
channel as well uh from uh the uh
Substack, Patreon, and much more. So
everybody, thanks so much uh uh for
joining me. Sorry we couldn't get to
questions. We are short on time. Um I
really appreciate all of you for all
your support in this time and for of
course spreading the message far and
wide, which can be done by hitting the
like button. That will keep this show
going. Without further ado, everyone,
uh, have a good rest of your, uh, week
weekend and, uh, we will continue with
the updates on this war. All right, take
care. Thank you again, Professor J.
Anything you want to say to the audience
as we head out of here?
>> No. Thanks for watching.
>> All right, bye-bye.